Identify the hypothesis and
conclusion of the following
statement, and determine whether
the statement is
always, sometimes,
or never true.
And the statement here is, the
absolute value of x is greater
than 0 for all real numbers x.
Now if I want to decide what the
hypothesis and conclusion
is here, it's usually a lot
easier to figure them out if
you rewrite this statement, this
exact statement, as an
if/then statement.
So what this statement is saying
is, if x is a real
number, then the absolute value
of x is greater than 0.
So let me rewrite that.
If x is a real number, then
the absolute value of x is
greater than 0.
These are equivalent
statements.
Now when you write it like
this, it's much easier to
identify the hypothesis
and the conclusion.
The hypothesis you can view as
it's the if part of this
proposition.
So this right here is
the hypothesis.
x is a real number.
That is the hypothesis.
And the conclusion
is the then part.
Sometimes it's called
the consequent.
It's this part right here.
It's this part, x.
Absolute value of x
is greater than 0.
This is the conclusion
or the consequent.
And over here, if you wanted
to circle them, this is the
conclusion.
That is the conclusion.
And the hypothesis is for
all real numbers.
It's a little bit easier to
identify when you see it
written like this.
This is the hypothesis.
Now I don't want you to get
confused with the idea of a
scientific hypothesis,
which is related but
a little bit different.
A scientific hypothesis is an
explanation for some phenomena
that can be tested.
So a scientific hypothesis
might be something like
saying, blueberries-- which
I'm writing in blue
intentionally.
Blueberries help reduce
the risk of cancer.
This right here is a scientific
hypothesis.
You could then go feed a bunch
of people blueberries for a
long period of time and see if
they have a less likelihood of
developing cancer than people
who never got blueberries and
everything else is equal.
And so it would be testable.
You could see if it's true.
And the conclusion would be
whether this is true or not.
But this is in the scientific
hypothesis world, not to be
confused with the notion
of hypothesis that
we're using right now.
And I don't want to confuse
you too much, so I'm just
going to leave this
on the side here.
But when you're in Algebra I
and especially-- these are
according to the California
standards.
The hypothesis in this context
is the antecedent of this
proposition.
Or it's the if part of
this proposition.
Now, the more interesting
question is
whether it is true.
I mean, we can sit and label
statements all day, but that's
not interesting.
The more fundamental thing is,
is this a true statement?
Is it true that if x is a real
number, then the absolute
value of x is greater than 0?
Well the one number that pops
out of my mind that disproves
this is if x is 0.
0 is a real number.
That's true.
But-- and I'll write
but in caps.
BUT the absolute value
of 0 is equal to 0.
It's not greater than 0.
So this disproves
this statement.
It's definitely not
always true.
Now, if you pretty much have
any other real number, this
will be true.
Because any other real number is
some distance away from 0.
That's what the absolute
value measures.
So if you took a 1 or a negative
1 or whatever, the
absolute value of those
are greater than 0.
So this is sometimes true.